chers amis chers ennemis bonsoir c'est
l'heure de rive droite rive gauche le
seul jt de la culture en compagnie ce
soir de patrick poivre d'arvor au
sommaire musique est la une avec la
sortie du nouveau chris isaac ross good
tenait depuis notre coup de coeur pour
les paravents de genêt version
marionnettes ou au théâtre de la colline
ensuite le pari des galeries arpentés
par jérôme cassou et enfin notre visite
guidée du ciné des cinéastes de l'avenue
de clichy sans oublier bien sûr les
interviews portraits de thierry ardisson
aujourd'hui ça sera moi et puis
l'instant réduit consacré au théâtre
avec notre tragi-comique duo philippe
tesson jacques nerson et incluant le
premier épisode de notre saga consacrée
au festival d'avignon
ce soir la réflexion de la cour
d'honneur du palais des papes
thierry qu'est-ce que vous aurez à rien
dans tout ça mais moi je vais vous
interviewez je vais parler un petit peu
de votre désir de littérature comment
l'homme le plus regardé de france à ce
désir de décrire d'être reconnu dans le
militaire dans des prix littéraires
voilà ça m'intéresse est de mon désir
d'être à votre place une fois avec mon
temps philippe vous avez bien joué ce
rôle là j'adore vous êtes de quel côté
du miroir de l'autre côté lumière
moi je vais parler théâtre comme
d'habitude avec jacques personnes c'est
mon comparse du lundi ont vanté à
trembler puis en l'innocence l'innocent
dit l'autre et puis le lundi on dispute
un peu on va parler de shakespeare son
génie d'été la mouette de tchekhov est
classique tout ça c'est bien et puis les
voisins de vina vers ça c'est pas du
kotayk frédéric c'est marrant parce
qu'il est il est trés muséologie silva
profil bas l'épi et puisque vous siégez
tous les deux à l'interallié alors
maintenant je siégeais la guerre c'était
juste le temps que j'ai eu une fois
après pratiquement daclin non mais non
c'est pas vrai
eh bien moi j'ai une nouvelle rubrique
qui s'appelle l'éreintement du lundi qui
a été créée spécialement pour la
traversée du miroir de
aux éditions balland voilà que l'indicé
le jour 2
alors tout le monde reconnaît l'écrivain
patrick poivre d'arvor mais peu de gens
savent qu'il présente aussi le 20 heures
de tf1 et donc comme il est là on va en
profiter pour parler un petit peu de
revenir un petit peu sur la façon dont
le pen a été traitée est ce qu'il ya une
rage pour ce 8 est vraiment des médias
sur ce qui s'est passé dans des
élections du 21 avril ayant laissé
beaucoup à dire alors on commence aussi
par la sortie du nouveau chris isaak
always goes tout net c'est un huitième
cd ressemblant comme un frère au
précédent et dans lequel le isaac égrène
un chapelet de bluesy blue est formaté
fm bref pour jérôme reijasse ce nouveau
crise ne fait pas de miracle
chris isaak est un nostalgique des
années 50-60 ce chanteur crooner à la
gueule d'ange déchu ressuscite l'esprit
d'elvis presley depuis 1985 aujourd'hui
il sort un nouvel album au boss got
tonight indices qui comme tous ses
prédécesseurs auraient pu être mises en
boîte il ya 40 ans même s'il s'en défend
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peu
elle mesdames
[Musique]
e
et c'est un voyage de chris isaak a
écrit la plupart de ses nouveaux
morceaux loin de tous bords du temps
[Musique]
restreint notre mine pour
l'actrice line renaud annie barrows à
[Musique]
afin de nous
et même si les chansons de chris isaak
peuvent parfois sonner assez commercial
même s'il possède son propre site comme
à la télé même s'ils jouent les acteurs
par intermittence pour le septième art
il refuse de se laisser aller à jouer
des stars préférant aux soirées
branchées le calme de son salon pour
composer
[Musique]
merci jérôme reijasse on continue avec
mon interview portrait aujourd'hui
patrick poivre d'arvor re bonsoir donc
vous re publié chez balland la traversée
du miroir nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure avec mes camarades à commencer
par frédéric beigbeder je veux parler un
petit peu de vous vous êtes présentateur
donc du 20 heures de tf1 est l'homme le
plus regardé de france est ce que vous
n'avez pas le sentiment ce n'est pas
pour disques quand on les photographies
on leur vole leur âme est ce que si vous
avez ce sentiment là est ce le fait
d'être l'homme le plus regardé de france
est-ce que ça va vite de quelque chose
non mais je pense que je dois avoir
plusieurs étiquettes il ya une étiquette
qui appartient aux autres c'est sur un
filtre devant l'objectif cela leur
appartient et c'est normal c'est leur
vision de deux mois puis j'en ai
d'autres j'ai même une marionnette
gilles initiale de très nature non non
ça va je m'en sors assez bien au milieu
de tout ça dans noyau dur je m'en sors
des maillots d'heure s'en sort bien
alors vous donnait pourtant beaucoup de
mal pour publier régulièrement des
livres on en a encore la preuve
aujourd'hui même si c'est une rue
publication pour entretenir de bonnes
relations avec le milieu littéraire pour
animer des émissions littéraires
consacré aux livres sur tf1 et sur lci
est-ce qu'on vous donnant tout ce mal
vous n'êtes pas le sentiment donner
l'impression finement de vous racheter
de cette gloire médiatique un peu facile
un peu futile je n'ai pas l'impression
je sais que c'est pas mon désir de
départ mon désir de départ c'est quelque
chose qui est née quand j'avais 13 14 15
ans j'ai écrit d'ailleurs mon premier
livre à cette époque là donc je pourrais
pas du tout à la télévision c'est venu
après le le coeur de ma passion c'est le
lire j'ai essayé de défendre comme j'ai
pu et d'ailleurs dans les beaux moments
de télévision moi j'ai le souvenir de du
jour vous avez reçus un 7 d'or pour
justement votre particulier une émission
culturelle et ça ça vous a fait je pense
hélas plus plaisir que des tas de succès
elle assure audimétrique que vous êtes
très généreux parce que quand on voit
vos émissions littéraires sur lci ou sur
tf1 vous invitez pas obligatoirement des
stars vous invitez d'aider des écrivains
un peu je dirais pas le les seconds
couteaux enfin les écrivains que les
veines probablement je les aime je les
comprends j'arrive à comprendre ce que
peut être la détresse de quelqu'un à
camille deux ans et moins trois ans dix
ans à écrire un livre j'essaie de ne pas
trop l'abîmé peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs fut pas assez pugnace pas
assez méchant pas assez cynique mais je
participe alors à leur travail
d'élaboration puis si possible un peu de
promotion si je veux les aider à être
lue par deux trois personnes décédées
des gens compagnies ne font pas la une
des magazines non je sais je mais ça me
paraît normal ça me paraît comment dire
peut-être pour revenir à votre première
question une façon de rendre un petit
peu justice à ce sort qui m'a donné
beaucoup de bonheur que je redonne je
redistribue du bonheur vous avez eu le
prix interallié c'était le premier prix
importantes vous ayez eu pour vous ça
vaut ça vaut combien de sept d'or un
prix interallié mantoue et 7 dans tous
les sens
très profondément les allées les
récompenses du milieu télévisuel ne
m'intéresse je connais un peu trop la
manière dont ça fonctionne non le milieu
littéraire bien sûr c'est normal quand
on a 12 13 ans et qu'on se dise que je
veux un grand écrivain et quand on a
comme espérance
quelque chose entre stendhal et c'est
chateaubriand me veut dire qu'on a mis
la barre assez haut qu'on se dit je vais
diplomate pour être un grand écrivain et
écrire justement des livres géniaux
éternel impérissable dans des ambassades
à l'anguille est qu'un jour il vous avez
eu une petite récompense de cette nature
on est vachement attend plus de bonheur
à mon avis plus de valeur le patrick
poivre d'arvor qui restera à votre avis
c'est le présentateur du 20 heures où
l'écrivain tu sais pas j'ai tendance à
penser que les journaux télévisés sont
oubliés au moment même où on dit au
revoir parce qu'elle a un autre qui va
suivre derrière je crois qu'on les
oublie très vite des gens qui ont marqué
la télévision je dis oui oui on met bien
sûr le nom on dira toujours quelque
chose que tout ce que vous êtes comme là
depuis quelques temps mais un paquet de
22 ans mais bon c'est pourquoi j'ai dit
oui je ne pense les gens se souviendront
évidemment de de la personne qui
représentent elles ont été visés pendant
aussi longtemps on assure n'a longtemps
parlé de gicquel qui l'homme présentait
lui pendant six ans donc il
vraisemblable on en parlera peut-être
encore un peu plus longtemps mais au
fait plus peut-être s'est pas mêlé
l'ivresse la vente un livre est un des
bibliothèques on peut les retrouver en
2050 caché dans une langue une vieille
bibliothèque
quelqu'un peut les aimer à nouveau puis
il y aura sept auteurs étaient méconnus
ou connu pour de mauvaises raisons ce
jamais
disparaître dans l'anonymat total alors
pourquoi dans ce pays tout le monde veut
être écrivain serre que même les prisons
la république giscard mitterrand se
piquer d'écriture
le présentateur du journal télévisé même
si j'ai commencé à écrire très jeune
vous l'avez dit mais pourquoi en france
le statut d'écrivain est ce qu'il ya de
mieux finalement mais je pense qu'il ya
une vraie culture de l'écrit et essai
c'est pour ça qu'on est à mon sens plus
fort plus armé pour le 21e 22e 23e
siècle parce qu'on s'y est pris depuis
si longtemps on adore ça profondément
nador sage contre une religion décrit
une religion du
du du mot alors le verbe c'est autre
chose le verbe c'est une invention est
relativement récente bon on utilise
comme des autres on fait ce qu'on peut
mais je pense qu'il ya un respect énorme
vivier de l'objet livre paraît assez de
le rester ses stats ultime effet dans
france un oui oui pour beaucoup
l'utilisent bien sûr mouais mais c'est
pas mal au fond c'est pas si mal mais ça
que beaucoup l'utilisent il ya des
livres inintéressant bien entendu mais
s'il permet de faire lire d'autres
diffusent je suis par contre alors vous
vivez votre vie un peu comme un roman
d'ailleurs vous avez suffisamment
transformé votre nom pour qu'il devienne
le mandat héros de roman vous avez
beaucoup insisté sur votre ascendance
bretonne même cv un peu lointaine et
puis quand on regarde votre enfant c'est
votre adolescence on y voit tous les
ingrédients du roman d'apprentissage
une enfance un peu pas malheureusement
un peu terne on peut dire non j'avais
des parents qui m'aimait mégère est
restée très solide
très timide votre père jacques poivre et
et représentants dans la chaussure
toujours sur les routes qui sont allés
pour quinze jours trois semaines des
fois donc tiens peut pas abandonner
m'enfin vous retrouvez votre mère ouais
mais ma mère s'occupait bien de nous et
c'est sûr que la figue loin paraître
paternel était plus lointaines oui je
pense que je me suis assez vite réfugier
dans la compagnie des livres pour toutes
ces raisons alors vous avez désir de
gloire pas de gloriole télévisuelle du
moment de gloire taglang avec panache
vous rêviez parlé tout à l'heure de
stendhal de châteaubriant de cyrano de
napoléon la police
j'ai bref c'est quand on habite reims
que la plaine et morne qui se passe
jamais rien qui fait il ya la brouille à
ce que c'est qu'on a le droit de la
glaise assez à ses godasses que quand on
vit dans les godasses justement puisque
mon pet dans chaussures qu'on se
promenaient dimanche pour aller voir les
autres magasins de chaussures faire des
comparatifs demain et c'est peut-être
qu'on a le désir de les prendre ses
godasses et petit speech se taillait
quoi me dépite de devenir un grand
bonhomme et je pense que beaucoup de
gens ont eu le désir oui l'a emporté à
paris bien sûr à nous de paris
absolument c'est un vrai roman
d'apprentissage
très jeune sentiments vous resteriez pas
là dans cette famille que vous étiez
appelé à dos un destin plus non j'étais
persuadé au contraire d'être d'être
obligé d'en laisser tout ce que je vous
disais la clé on ne bouge pas on ne
bouge pas parce qu'on est le déterminant
parce que parce que socialement on doit
être ce qu'on est parce que vos parents
vous ont fait l'essai vous laissez
entendre que d'être médecin par exemple
est ce qu'ils avaient de plus je voyais
des chiffres tout ça puis voilà donc on
pense pas tout de suite et alors
évidemment ce rebelle est allé de soi
puis à un moment donné ont réussi à
briser les jeunes a donné l'idée de
partir la force de partir les livres les
livres les lives à chaque fois je voyais
est un petit gars qui montait à paris ça
me plaît ce soit dans sa famille j'ai un
sourire tout je prends tout alors quand
tous les cas très jeune très homme
pressé là aussi on reste on reste dans
le roman à saison vous aviez votre deux
bacs vous aviez déjà écrit un livre qui
s'appelle mouyabi aida les prémices des
enfants de l'autre vous avez publié plus
tard vous avez déjà un enfant aussi à
saison donc très pressé peur de pas y
arriver tous et sans doute nous il ya
bien d'assas et d'un mont polonais
guillaume à ma douleur ma souffrance
j'avais trouvé ça sur des lettres de
chopin qu'il avait écrit à sa fiancée de
l'époque et ça va ça va aller bien bien
plus j'avais écrit ce livre qui est
devenu en effet plus tard les enfants
tout regret et voilà j'ai eu envie de
rêver ma vie tout ou presque tout le
temps un tout le temps je pense que
l'univers l'ivresse dans lequel j'ai été
fabriqué donc pour les raisons que je
vous ai dit
ça a fait que j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
avec le réel et le même aujourd'hui
encore alors pas beaucoup d'argent pour
payer vos études est obligé de
travailler même si vous rêvez diplomate
vous êtes magasinier livreur contrôleurs
dans les trains ne fera pas n'importe
quel sera comme les wagons lits les
données ont du coeur d'effacer rennes
producteur je produis j'ai rien du tout
mais les contrôleurs en effet paris
venise quand même je faisais paris
venise paris modane l'épée innsbruck
mais kloto paris venu mais ça ça m'a
bien oui tout ça j'ai découvert venise
serait la neige c'est ce week end suite
venise pendant leurs élèves savent ou
norman homme est alors vous prenez le le
virus du journalisme en 68 quand vous
distribuez au carrefour saint germain
saint michel le monde et françois quoi
vous vendiez le journal dans la rue oui
oui c'était pour me faire un peu
d'argent alors j'avais repéré un peu
l'économie de l'époque était assez
bordélique vous en souvenez sans doute y
avait donc tous et toutes ces grèves
beaucoup d'embouteillages dans les rues
puis je me dis l'aller les journaux ça
marchait vraiment très très bien
l'époque et je suis allée acheter
vraiment à l'angle du boulevard saint
germain du bois saint michel des du
démon depuis des jeux croix à l'époque
la 35 centimes me semble utile et j'ai
acheté la part compris j'ai volé et
vendu après je suis revenu il me dira
mais c'est vraiment gentil mais vous
êtes bête vous fait pas d'argent avec ça
mais je me faisais juste pour boire à
les rues saint d'entrée des arts et là
il y avait une petite camionnette qui
vendait des jo des journaux comme ça un
peu moins cher et je les ai revendues à
mon tour puisque voilà j'en vendais 300
par jour un peu de monde est un peu de
france voir l essai la croissance visée
de vue tu veux avoir mon nom dans ce
journal non non j'ai pas pensé à demain
non non non non non j'ai toujours mon
idée oui le nom dans le journal
éventuellement metouali diversité mais
sur cette idée là dans la suite on la
connaît on va parvenir vos succès et vos
échecs vos bonheurs vos malheurs une
chose qu'on n'a jamais très bien compris
c'est comment vous gériez vos relations
avec la presse en général celle des fois
vous êtes très impudique et puis des
fois on converse très énervé devant les
assauts des paparazzi mais moi je suis
jamais public je raconte ce que je veux
dans les livres avec la licence poétique
romanesque quelques est permise j'ai
jamais raconter ma vie ni sentimentale
ni autre dans mes livres je vais
raconter ma fille que parce qu'elle me
l'a demandé une fois ces solène est là
elle souffrait d'anorexie une première
fois puis une deuxième fois lorsque
lorsqu'elle est morte c'est à peu près
la seule chose j'en suis même sûr que
j'ai racontée deux mois je n'ai jamais
raconté qu'on a appris que vous vous a
été volée à tout tout le temps je n'ai
jamais donné mon
copyright mon accord au contraire ça m'a
souvent été extorqués dans des
conditions même parfois c'est
épouvantable c'est comme souvent ça
arrive vous réagissez comme ans devant
la devant la télé réalité justement
cirque e bonds love story disons qu'en
corse est acceptable mais quand vous
voyez par exemple que tf1 va faire
temptation island c'est à dire une île
où des couples on va essayer de détruire
des couples en envoyant des des jeunes
filles très jolie ou des garçons très
beau enfin bon ça va jusque là où voir
des émissions américaines comme le camp
et c est ce que un mot vous dit pas
moralement il faut que je m'en aille
faudrait que ce soit sur une chaîne qui
fait pas de ce genre de télévision que
j'aime pas c'est d'abord l'acception du
mot de télé réalité c'est tout sauf la
réalité c'est pour moi la réalité les
dans les jt dans le journal télévisé
ensuite son on sait que c'est très
scénarisé c'est très organisés sans et
même des merlans profondément merdes ans
est encore suivi apparemment les gens
continuent à se passionner moi ça ne me
passionne pas du tout je dis la vérité
je ne te passionne pas les barrières
morales les ai vu sauter surtout dans
des émissions type il y en a une sur
rtl9 qui progresse celle là je trouve
sinon vrai c'est dire si on est sur une
émission de dénonciation la haie et la
sagem font des membres mais sans que
simon so we weed sûr
mais finalement la finalité d'une chaîne
commerciale qui est d'enrichir ses
actionnaires et c'est normal et c'est
quelque part c'est pas choquant est ce
que quelqu'un comme vous avec les
préoccupations littéraires
intellectuelle que que vous avez est ce
que vous seriez pas plus à votre place
finalement sur une chaîne de service
public où l'ambition n'est pas de faire
des bénéfices mais simplement je dirais
même si ce n'est pas toujours le cas
bien entendu
d'informer les gens décident les
cultiver de leur apprendre quelque chose
est ce que vous vous devriez pas mettre
en accord la chaîne sur laquelle vous
êtes avec vos préoccupations
j'ai commencé dans le service public à 3
ans à france inter et puis disent
ensuite sur la deux
j'ai été assez vite déçu par la
tentation du pouvoir d'être s'occuper de
tous de nous conduire justement c'est ce
dont il faut parler de ne pas parler etc
sam était assez insupportable donc j'ai
assez mêlé hilali beaucoup aimé même la
liberté qu'on m'a offert de dire tout ce
que je voulais dans mon cadre à moi vous
dire que je cautionne tout ce qui est
autour de moi non je sais j'en serais
incapable et je suis franc en même temps
je ne vois plus trop bien la frontière
entre le service public et le privé moi
il me semble que la satisfaction elle ne
doit pas être celle des actionnaires est
plutôt celle des téléspectateurs me
semble-t-il alors on va parler de tf1 on
va reparler avec nos camarades tout à
l'heure il ya deux trois points discutés
en tous les cas merci je rappelle le
titre du livre qu'on en reparle dans un
instant la traversée du miroir donc de
patrick poivre d'arvor c'est chez
balland voilà après les pubs on se
retrouve en votre compagnie
[Musique]
chers amis chers ennemis re on se
retrouve avec patrick poivre d'arvor
pour la reddition chez balland de la
traversée du miroir
patrice le pitch alors comme vous l'avez
dit réédition réécriture puisque du
livre était par ailleurs 85 et puis vous
l'avez re et crie au change et la fin
notamment j'ai changé la première ligne
et les deux derniers des deux dernières
fois j'adore l'histoire en deux mots le
rideau peut se lever pour aller c'est
l'histoire d'un médecin qui s'appelle
alexis d'orgeuil il ya une quarantaine
d'années
et que tu es marié à une femme qui
s'appelle laurence kit séducteur
les femmes tombent assez facilement tout
est bon les uns les clientes
suspects passagers de l'époque
ça facilite hoc va évidemment l approche
alors et puis à force d'avoir ces
coquette doaks pose des questions sur
lui-même et se cherche qui ne se trouve
pas et un jour il décide de tout
abandonner et de partir ils arrivent à
médecins sans frontières et puis part en
thaïlande et après la thaïlande il il va
chez les khmers rouges au cambodge il
passe comme ça il est fait prisonnier et
février pendant trois ans elle dans des
conditions absolument atroce dire qu'il
assiste à des tortures il faut rien
faire lui-même et hors du rectangle
enseveli un moment
terrible
et puis au bout de trois ans il réussit
à s'évader on peut aller jusque là il
réussit à s'évader y revient alors ça
c'est un peu le rêve de tout homme que
tout le monde le croit mort y revient
jusqu'à chez lui jusqu'à paris à
l'envers cartes et qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'est devenue sa femme personne ne le
reconnaît vraiment ce qui lui permet de
ba de prendre divers rôles de revenir
auprès des siens de voir comment ils ont
violé de savoir ce qu'ils pensent de lui
ce qu'ils disent de lui et puis bon
après je raconte pas la finlande serait
un peu dommage voilà en gros le
l'histoire se valent oui oui oui c'était
raconter assez souvent mais volpone par
exemple c'est vrai quoi elles produisent
un personnage comme ça qu'il adore
entendre ce qu'on peut dire de lui ou
dans le retour de martin guerre aussi
soyeux ca il ya quelque chose de plus
que ça il ya aussi la volonté de
reconquérir sa femme alors
le petit plus c'est petit plus c'est
gros plus c'est très important c'est un
temp interiale c'est le thème de
trahison de pin terre qui a été
absolument superbe devenir l'amant de sa
femme
ok que ça il ya ça moi personnellement
ça m'a beaucoup plus touchés que
l'histoire du médecin séducteur du oui
qui va chercher l'aventurière ça j'ai
trouvé ça très je trouve que c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus intéressant mais c'est
à dire mais vous
changez de disparaître changer de vie
bah oui c'est laval avantage justement
on change de tête on n'est pas reconnue
bon là en plus singulièrement à l'époque
quand je l'avais écrite très connu mais
on commence à dire une petite notoriété
mais changer de tête complètement chars
refaire sa vie et elle reconquérir qui
l'ont vue y compris son premier amour
vie ça sonne bien fantasme deux
bâtonnets pathologique narcissique
ira quand il dit que ses beats d'actéon
c'est juste un peu mieux mais je me
rappelais plus le mythe d'actéon actes
et anti-chasse quelque chose d'absolu
qu'ils croient trouver dans la femme en
vérité il ne fait que renvoyer sa quête
à son propre besoin de chasseurs il
devient gibier ses désirs le dévore il
veut s'enfuir mais il est trop tard
c'est à la limite ça donne en effet bien
connu c'est là le problème dans sa tente
de séducteur de playboy ou de
consommateurs qui se noie comme d'autres
se noie dans la drogue ou dans l'alcool
se noie dans les femmes mais en
consommant consomment jusqu'à
l'écoeurement en bleu il se trouve que
c'est son instrument de travail si je
puis dire à la main puisqu'il est
gynécologue et qui à l'espé de moment où
il a des goûts total de lui un mille
approche de la quarantaine il est
vraiment mais que river changé de vie je
pense qu'il est assez sincère dans la ce
moment là quand ils désirent s'engager
dans une organisation humanitaire ça se
faisait beaucoup dans les années 80 on
aller comme ça mais ça du monde ou à
médecins sans frontières et puis il va
là bas et il n'empêche que il est quand
même poursuivi par ses fantômes par ses
démons et qu' il va pas s'empêcher de de
retrancher encore avec laly tcm j'ai
voulu faire quelque chose autour
justement oui entraînement l'air très
court a cantonné aux pratiques mettent
un peu de moral
haut du
corps qui fuit complètement ya aucun
coût non mais c'est vrai ce
qui lui arrive et puis de temps après il
change la fare les sens quand même une
petite new york est allé chez
sa femme lui mais dit une petite
vengeance à sa façon que je trouve assez
bien trouver de la part de la femme de
l'auteur je sais pas ce qu'ils avaient
de calais voilà ce qu'on peut filer la
métaphore à s'allonger oui et je me suis
demandé donc quand vous êtes 20 quand le
héros pardon et prisonniers
dont des khmers rouges
si ce n'était pas une métaphore du
journal télévisé parce qu'elle lui
présente parce qu'au fond de
présentateurs de journaux télévisés des
eaux il est prisonnier dans son bocal
comme ça dans son studio ah oui
et vous dites d'ailleurs j'ai accepté
tout et je ne laissait paraître aucune
émotion c'est pas un peu sa
représentativité chantera plus des
villes et l'accepter ce n'était pas
l'idée de départ quand j'ai
copié sur ce livre pour écrire
plateforme puisque elle raconte aussi
l'histoire de quelqu'un qui sonde en
thaïlande ouais vous étiez un précurseur
quand même 14
non ce qui est vrai c'est que dans
l'oeuvre ppd est ce qu il ya plein de
différentes sortes de livia des romans
historiques dont celui qui est le prix
interallié l'irrésolu il ya des romans
plus personnel dont je crois la
traversée du miroir fait partie
pourquoi avoir eu envie maintenant de
réaliser celui là le point de départ il
faut que je sois honnête ce n'était pas
une idée de moi c'est une idée du nouvel
éditeur parce qu'ils seront plus ballan
qui était comme son nom l'indiqué
dirigée par andré balland a changé de
mains plusieurs fois et que est
aujourd'hui se retrouvent dirigé par
denis bourgeois qui a vu que ce livre
était épuisé et m'a proposé alors dans
un premier temps je vous dis non je n'ai
jamais relu mes livres et je pense que
les livres ont ils sont faits pour vivre
et puis après henri devienne ce qu'ils
deviennent et puis alors après il m'a
dit mais si ça serait bien je les fais
pour dominique fernandez pour cette
droite et relie le quand même je les
relis je les trouvais je trouvais qu'ils
tenaient le relativement le coup sauf la
fin alors la fin je me suis souvenu de
la manière dont il avait écrit te et
c'était je crois dans un train parce que
là je fais des tours du monde en train
pour paris match j'avais créé à toute
vitesse et la fin était très bâclée et
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai changé
et puis je pense qu'au fond un livre le
droit de vivre il devrait d'abord jamais
être remis puisqu'il n'est jamais
terminée on peut toujours trouver à
le polir davantage et puis il fit quoi
comme une femme comme un homme il a le
droit d'avoir une nouvelle vie et ça m'a
plu voilà ça au fond je me suis pris au
jeu mais c'était pas une idée de départ
puisque je les sors c'est entre le roman
historique de vous parliez de stendhal
le roman un peu du maintien si on est
gentil et max gallo lien si on est
méchant et le roman plus personnel vous
n'arrivez pas à choisir
si maintenant je crois que j'ai vraiment
envie d'aller au plus profond de
moi-même comme toujours je pense que
plus on avance en âge et plus on va au
coeur du bonhomme jammu et j'aime les
romans où je laisse transparaître des
petits cailloux de moi et puis où quand
même je creuse mais évidemment il faut
un petit avis j'aime pas je ne saurais
pas bien faire le dos rond
le font très bien ça serait drôle
autofiction de
proposer un jour il m'a dit qu'il
faudrait que j'écrive un roman qui
s'appellera ppda roman ouais mais oui
geniez d'olt je laisse ça à d'autres
pays la claire castillon par exemple lui
pour un troll goût du masque pour écrire
ppda roman luis attend les masques
j'adore les bleus dans ce livre je me
suis retrouvé moi même des petits des
petits trucs des petits j'avais laissé
comme ça c'était juste destiné à une ou
deux paires noël j'avais trouvé dit oui
brisant ses bouquins dans les réseaux
lui le héros selanne a
d'abord bien moi et ça j'aimais bien
cette idée là au fond qu'on pouvait
s'amuser faire des pieds n'est la
littérature c'est caen nantes et sa
prison oui oui parce que les lives en
fait on s'en rend pas compte mais les
lits sont des affaires graves et parfois
on publie des livres on croit qu'on a
toute liberté et en fait on n'a pas en a
de liberté vis-à-vis de soi-même c'est
déjà beaucoup les vidéos dont on n'a pas
dit et les autres prennent ça souvent
mal évidemment évidemment je me suis
très bien d'un livre j'avais écrit et
keith commencer par l'enterrement de mon
grand père ma grand mère l'a vécu ça
l'est mais ne pouvant pas parce que
j'essaie d'imaginer ses maîtresses dans
le dans l'église tous alors penser à
autre chose évidemment faux maîtresse du
grand père aviateur mais moi j'ai trouvé
ça formidable cible aviateurs il avait
des maîtresses était bien joué et on
écrit avec mon frère tous les deux c'est
un livre qu'on avait écrit à deux et il
était parti lui aussi l'avait chevauchée
ses fantasmes là et ma pauvre en mer qui
nous a do ré mais qu'est ce que j'ai
fait à mes enfants mes petits enfants
pour qu'ils se vengent comme ça on se
venge et pas du tout on pensait même
qu'on était en train de lui installer un
mausolée grand-père et vous voyez pas
que ça il ya hélas beaucoup de gens
comme ça et je ne pensais pas blesser
gérer gratiné où
j'ai fait souffrir peut l'être si
c'était à refaire vous préféreriez la
télé ou la littérature parce que c'est
une question qui moi me concerne
concerne aussi thierry aussi on en fait
tous les gens autour de cette table on
est tenté par la télé en même temps la
vérité j'aime beaucoup la littérature
ceux ci s'ils avaient vraiment ce choix
s'ils étaient drastiques s'il fallait
choisir je choisirais la littérature
mais de la même manière que je disais à
thierry tout à l'heure
j'aimais l'idée de du 19e on était
écrivain diplomate alors on aimerait
quand même officiellement bon il saint
john perse tout le monde ma maman et le
matin oui mon rang c'est à dire de
l'argent ces gens écrivent et des choses
et brice et leur statut social et il
était là pour rédiger des télégrammes
diplomatiques pour repérer l'état du
monde bon ben voilà d'une certaine façon
je rédigeais télégramme pas trop
dramatique et je regarde un peu l'état
du monde donc mon métier de base c'est
le journaliste quand même pas très léger
vrai mais c'est vrai quand même toi tu
es démange plus que une ambassade
lointaine mais en même temps d'autres
sans doute mais en même temps fourni
aussi d'autres
mais c'est une autre théorie que vous
avez connu est pas sorti de thaler les
je pense qu'il est en train de s'assurer
une
une retraite agréable parce que vieux
présentateur télé 7 jours ce minable
alors que vieil écrivain vieille
académiciens que c'est beaucoup plus
cher c'est vrai moi je pense que il
assure ses arrières on serait bien très
adroitement il est vrai qu'à partir du
moment où j'ai publié mon premier livre
j'étais beaucoup plus assurée vis-à-vis
de la télévision c'est à dire que je
n'avais pas le sentiment que s'ils ont
piqué mon siège comme ça jamais
d'arriver en gagnant 23 que c'était la
fin du mans le la fin de monde elle
continuait le monde continue et j'avais
un autre monde et j'ai vu des gens qui
dans notre métier on en effet eu
l'impression que tout s'écroule et
soucieuse que ce qu'il n'y avait plus
rien il y avait pu taire il y avait plus
de et qu'il était plus rien
c'est bien la situation si on perd son
boulot mon ami
génial
une enquête du journal s'appelle médias
hier et demain sur reculera pas alors
comment les comment les médias ont
traité le pen c'est vrai que plusieurs
techniques de suite il ya eu la censure
après elle ce rex position après eu
l'agressivité après avoir essayé de les
traiter comme un autre ça n'a jamais
vraiment marché dans l'idée qu'avait les
gens c'est à dire de réduire un peu le
front national on la verra bien et puis
il ya les deux accusations assez
contradictoire de l'air dont ont fait
l'objet les journaux
la première c'est les journaux font
monter le pen ils ont trop parlé de
l'insécurité ça on va paraître dans un
instant et c'est notamment la télévision
qui est accusé et puis deuxième
accusation contraire mais c'est vrai
qu'elle correspondait à deux temps
différent de la campagne c'est au
contraire on a assisté entre les deux
tours à une une
la charge médiatique
c'était l'après soviétique gabonaise et
c'est donc
alors je reviens tout petit peu soit
l'âge en effet sur est ce que la
télévision notamment alors il ya eu le
vote polémique avec julien dray qui dit
tf1 et fn vous devez répondre dans le
monde est ce que en effet il est des
faits divers la violence a été sur
traités pendant la campagne électorale
alors tout le monde discute et comme ça
en disant oui mais on ne fait que
montrer ce qu'ils existent les autres
qu'ils aient oui c'était sûr sur traité
et puis là on a des chiffres puisque y
ait une enquête qui était faite par la
sofres par un pool de la surface qui
savent tns media et qui montrent en
effet que il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de
sujets entre janvier et mai consacré à
la violence le nombre de sujets a
augmenté de 126 % entre février quand
même de consacrer aux faits divers la
violence entre free très particulier
nous y avait à la fois la tuerie de
nanterre voilà des tas d'événements et
puis les chiffres de la délinquance qui
était connue d'abord par les syndicats
de police puis ensuite par la fp puis
ensuite par officiellement parmi ces
l'intérieur si on montrait d'ailleurs
qu'il y avait en effet une hausse de
près de 8 % de la délinquance donc
offert que les chiffres sont faux ce
tout ça est très compliqué qui se serait
peut-être opérés sont fort bien
globalement si c'était plus une
actualité très janvier et alors d
amalgame très étrange fait parce qu'ils
font justement ce type d'étude et qui
disent ah oui mr vous ai parlé du procès
deal c'est pas bien il fait foutait la
trouille au gendre est d'abord c'est une
histoire qui date d'il ya 16 ans d'une
part car suite ça fait partie oui est ce
que c'est la sphère raddad est ce que
cela fait redresse us est ce que c'est
bon c'est intéressant will a versé
trouvait juste
les attentats du 11 septembre on a dix
terroristes plan vigipirate parler que
de sécurité mais c'est parce que ça
passionnés beaucoup les gens en france
qui comme disciple qui peut vous
intéresser aux centres de composition
qui font entre france 2 et tf1 le
rapport quand même sur le traitement de
la violence et de 1,4 pour le journal de
13 heures entre france 2 frères quatre
fois moins qu'en c'était l'argent c'est
normal et et sur le 20h que vous
présentez de 1 à 2 malheureusement j'ai
vu dans ray sur images que je n'avais
plus chez calyon g
moi je pense très honnêtement on a fait
le métier qu'il fallait faire à l'époque
c'est à dire tout dire tout le montrait
et je sais très bien que les pouvoirs
allez pouvoir en place d'abord me sens
assez souvent mauvais perdants quand ils
ont perdu la place toujours la faute de
tout le monde vous avez remarqué que
dans cette affaire oui les sondeurs les
abstentionnistes des petits candidats
qu'elle palois se présente mais des
vacances scolaires de 7 et puis fit in
fine est toujours des médias et première
soirée deuxièmement on a toujours envie
de vous dire ne parlez pas de ce qui
fâche et moi j'ai eu le droit ça avec
les grèves il ya sept ans n'était pas un
vain de gauche avec les grévistes depuis
hier 14 ans était un événement gauche je
sache c'est toujours comme ça donc moi
ce que je pense ce qu'il faut pas se
laisser intimider faut faire notre
métier et puis surtout me mettre en
perspective quand même les choses quand
il ya tel ou tel fait divers a fool dire
et puis relativisée montrer qui est
aussi notre tisser les invités par
exemple c'est vrai que sur tf1 c'est
avec des gens comme chances d'une oeuvre
ou pernod sont peut-être plus souvent à
l'avant-garde que vous sur le vol
sexualité c'est clair c'est ainsi perdu
et a grandi on ne sait pas de nom il est
plus question
quand julien dray dit fn vous lui
répondez dans le monde interdit de
séjour paraît-il sur tf1 et sur lci il
dit je vais je suis désolé mais ça fait
16 ans que oui c'est entre le journal de
tf1 que j'ai jamais invité de ma vie
ouais c'est pas et j'ai pas être méchant
avec lui mais il ya 7 577 députés en
france due au maximum on a évité une
petite dizaine d'hommes journal télévisé
il faut pas qu'ils prennent mal le fait
d'être invité je n'ai jamais invité on
sait d'envergure nationale à ce point
pour que il je sais qu'il aime les
médias qu'il a l'air de désiré même
c'était très très demandeurs mais bon
qui ne prennent pas mal en revanche
c'est vrai qu'il était invité sur lci
qu'il a été décommandé
une émission de jean-luc c'est de
pierre-luc sion parce qu'en effet il
venait de dire ça et qu'on lui a demandé
de s'excuser avant de revenir un peu le
dis je me suis rep ah moi je prends pas
tfn commun comme un qualificatif
formidable passe à peyrens dans sa
bouche c'était une insulte il ya
peut-être un problème plus plus
compliqué mais au fond c'est de se dire
le pen prenons le pen comme comme
exemple c'est vrai que là un discours
plus émotionnel que rationnel et c'est
vrai que la télévision et plus
émotionnelle elle même que rationnel
pour ça ça c'est un bon argument parce
que c'était intéressant comment se
débrouillent nous donnera ses boyaux la
wii comme face à l'émotionnel vous avez
en effet la tuerie de nanterre tuerie de
nanterre pour vous la lisez dans le
monde dans libération dans le figaro
mais ça peut pas et vous voyez des gens
voient des lieux déplacent même à la
limite des flaques de sang et de cession
fait attention pour être très digne les
uns les autres croyants dans ce film âge
mais évidemment le choc est très violent
et les violents aussi pour n'importe
quel fait divers donc nous comment on
peut réussir à atténuer leur me
semble-t-il dans la présentation c'est à
dire ne jamais ameuter les foules venez
à moi vous allez voir ce que vous allez
voir c'est formidable on va vous zoomez
sur des horreurs donc déjà première
chose à voir une voix plutôt calme
apaisé et de montrer et puis mettre les
choses en relation les unes avec les
autres faire des comparatifs avec
l'étranger par exemple dire qu'aux états
unis il ya quand même deux millions de
gens dans les prisons qui est de 50
mille en france fera bon jeu ça me
paraît pas inutile est ce qu'il n'ya pas
quand même aussi une critique on
pourrait faire à l'envers c'est que
depuis l'élection de chirac on a
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
sujets sur les faits divers et donc tout
d'un coup l'insécurité n'existe plus
moins 50% entre les deux tout faux
le mont dernier journal télévisé jeudi
dernier j'ai ouvert sur rien un problème
comme ça d'insécurité de grande
délinquance quelle est l attaque d'un
fourgon blindé
donc c'est ça fait l'ouverture de moanda
et celui de la 2 d'ailleurs mais en
l'occurence j'ai pas l'impression cible
dans l'entre-deux tours c'est
vraisemblable parce que effectivement il
ya une focalisation sur le débat
politique avait des manifestations des
contre-manifestations il y avait
beaucoup de est-ce que ce sera la
dernière question est ce que dans
l'entre-deux-tours vous avez pas été
facile vous êtes conscient que tout le
monde lui aussi jeudi en attaque on a
quand même dépassé un petit peu notre
rôle qu'on est allé des prescripteurs en
disant aux gens à peu près unanime vous
allez voter pour chirac alors c'est sans
doute ce qu'il fallait faire ce pas ce
que veut dire mais est ce que là d'un
seul coup ça reste démocratique non
c'est à dire je pense qu'on n'est plus
dans la démocratie quand chacun a le
droit d'avoir des opinions notamment la
presse d'opinion entre mathieu à la
vidéo c'est différent interview je pense
qu'on ne peut pas bon vous avez un jour
une émission militante mais vous ne
présentez pas le journal télévisé moi je
pense que je n'avais pas à dire aux gens
vous était un tel plutôt qu'un tel
message voilà pourquoi pas et et puis si
on relativise quand même les événements
puisque on peut avoir un peu de recul
quand même on se souviendra et philippe
tesson est un fin analyste de la chose
politique que le pen a déjà eu 14 pour
cent quatre-vingt-huit au terme du
premier septennat de mitterrand 15% en
95 au terme du deuxième septennat mi
temps et il sait % seulement si je puis
dire oui mais cette fois ci donc et 200
mille fois de plus qu'il ya sept ans
donc je crois qu'on peut relativiser
aussi sont en panique je comprends à en
gal a envahi les français veulent à
relativiser aussi bien merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci de vous êtes prêté à
notre petit jeu début de l'émission
c'est très très sympa patrick poivre
d'arvor a traversée du miroir donc c'est
chez balland merci patrick on poursuit
avec notre coup de coeur pour les
paravents de jean genet au théâtre de la
colline jusqu'au 14 juin
cette pièce anti algérie française dans
laquelle je n'ai de révolte et appelle à
la manif et dénonce les manip est
aujourd'hui interprété par des
marionnettes nippone fait des carbo est
allé se faire manipuler magnéto après
plusieurs voyages au japon frédéric
fisbach met en scène les paravents des
jean genet cette pièce avec ses 96
personnage écrites pendant la guerre
d'algérie est l'histoire d'une famille
d'exclus qui traverse un territoire en
guerre le metteur en scène l'a adapté
pour trois acteurs de récitant et
surtout une trentaine de marionnettes
traditionnelles japonaises de la
compagnie la kizad
le principe du théâtre traditionnel
japonais de marionnettes est très simple
il ya deux scènes à une scène pour
l'oeil et une scène pour l'oreille donc
il ya une scène où se déroule ce qu'on a
à voir sont les marionnettes avec les
marionnettistes qui sont à vue et dans
des décors qui sont aux dimensions des
marionnettes et puis sur le côté il ya
un aussi ferhat heures
depuis plus de trois siècles cette
compagnie pratique l'art de la
marionnette à fils pour la première fois
ils sont en france rencontre de deux
cultures et de deux mondes car ici
marionnettes et acteurs deviennent
partenaires de jeu
et un rapport à trouver qui est qui qui
est au début extrêmement compliqué parce
qu'il faut le il faut le construire en
fait il leva il ne va pas de soi ce que
naturellement les acteurs ont plutôt
tendance à jouer avec les manipulateurs
qu'avec les marionnettes dans certains
tableaux où les vivants et les morts
dialogue les marionnettes permettent de
donner vie aux fantômes au début je plus
le poser des questions je savais pas
comment on allait traiter cette histoire
des morts et 1 et puis je leur ai posé
la question j'aurais dit mais comment
est-ce que vous représentez les fantômes
par exemple comme chez vous anthony vol
et effectivement ils ont commencé à lui
et je trouve ça magnifique tellement
simple mais tellement beau aussi ça par
exemple en acteur peut difficilement le
faire pour cette création les
marionnettes ont subi quelques
adaptations à la demande du metteur en
scène
pendant qu aux autres thés noirs
casques à la d1 sur sa volonté
c'est pas des marionnettes qui sont
faites pour pour les pantalons puisque
c'est les mariages qui sont faites elles
n'ont pas bougé depuis 360 donc elles
sont faites pour les kimonos parce que
les gens ne peuvent pas se mettre droite
complètement et elles ont un mouvement
très très particulier solo était content
de nos fins notamment et bien vous notre
amélie mbow qui m'ont acheté ce matin
on ignore si paris hôpital à toulouse
finale
la marionnette elle a un côté sérieux
elle a un côté bon élève comme ça qui
fait qu'elle absorbe très bien
c'est tout ce qui pourrait apparaître un
peu caricaturale dans la pièce et 10 qui
du coup lll des graisses presque
l'écriture on a l'impression de voir
apparaître le coeur même le dire est le
nerf de l'écriture et on est beaucoup
plus sur le sens et sur l'histoire
merci frédéric arbois et après les pubs
place à l'instant critique aujourd'hui
consacré au théâtre avec notre
tragi-comique duo fit et songe à jane
eyre soient plus
chers amis chers ennemis re re on se
retrouve pour l'instant critique
aujourd'hui consacré au théâtre avec
notre tragi-comique duo philippe tesson
du fig mag de métro et de r d hergé et
jacques nerson de valeurs actuelles
bonsoir jacques alors on commence tout
de suite avec le premier épisode de
notre saga consacrée au festival
d'avignon ce soir la réfection de la
cour d'honneur du palais des papes une
scène à ciel ouvert qui pour sa
réouverture
accueil le plateau 9 de tchekhov revue
par eric lacascade karine roy s'est jeté
à l'eau magnéto
[Musique]
le palais des papes d'avignon est un
vrai chantier son dispositif scénique
n'avait pas été rénovée depuis 20 ans
avec un budget restreint de 2 millions
d'euros c'est guy claude françois connu
pour ses scénographies pour le théâtre
du soleil qui s'y colle et il était
temps
au bout de vingt ans elle était très
abîmée parce qu'on la démonte en amande
ça reste une salle ce vous imaginez un
théâtre condé monde tous les ans quoi
tout simplement ainsi les gras vins sont
en aluminium donc plus léger et
transportable ils sont d'un seul tenant
et pour le confort du public leur
capacité a été réduite de près de 400
places la scène est plus près des
spectateurs et a été surélevée la
sonorisation a été aussi améliorée
jacques e place de spectateur
bénéficiera d'un petit haut parleur qui
va être un haut parleur de renfort du
son il ya une pression depuis le
commencement de ce projet suit parce que
c'est un endroit mythique parce qu'on
n'a pas le droit à l'erreur c'est le
téméraire metteur en scène éric
lacascade qui va inaugurer le 5 juillet
prochain c'est toute nouvelle cour avec
platonov de tchekhov
nous avons pu filmer en exclusivité les
répétitions à caen où les comédiens
jouent dans un décor qui simule le
célèbre grand mur de la cour d'honneur
eric lacascade a ainsi choisi de
l'intégrer dans sa mise en scène
comme les deux premiers than de 4,9 ça
se passe dans la maison d'un ap3 là on
s'est dit que la maison c'était cet
espace de verticalité et que la fête du
début on allait essayer de la travailler
en fonction des fenêtres qui a sur la
façade du palais des papes c'est vrai
qu'on retarde le moment où on va
descendre sur ce plateau a priori dit
hostile et c'est pour ça que je voulais
qu'ils aient 20 minutes une demi heure
en verticalité pour les acteurs comme un
prologue comme un training pour les
spectateurs pour entrer tout doucement
dans cette histoire en ayant
l'impression de voler des moments d'être
là en
en petits voyeurs voleurs
l'intérêt c'est d'utiliser l'ensemble de
pour moi c'est d'utiliser l'ensemble de
l'amplitude de la cour que ce soit une
contrainte et que ce soit la chance pour
moi et pour le groupe d'acteurs de jouer
sur un plateau de 30 mètres ce qu'on
trouve rarement salle de jouer sous un
ciel étoilé ce qu'on trouve rarement
salle et de jouer devant 2000
spectateurs ce qu'on trouve rarement
salle c'est un pari c'est un enjeu c'est
une contrainte
[Musique]
sans faire un son et lumière il faut
juger temps pour moi j'essaye de garder
en tête que que la star du spectacle
c'est ni plateau neuf ni la cascade
c'est la cour d'honneur c'est un
personnage presque rival tout simplement
ce n'est pas à la hauteur des murs ce
n'est pas là la majesté du lieu je pense
que c'est un espace très très vivant et
ça fait peur bien sûr
merci karine roy avignon 2002 ça se
présente comment jacques un programme
alléchant
30 créations en théâtre à peu près à peu
près 17 française et 13 spectacles
étrangers un regret pour ma part c'est
il me semble qu'il n'ya qu'une créations
d'auteurs français en plus c'est un
texte de christophe wissman qui est déjà
enfin auteur qui a déjà été jouée
avignon et une à mon avis il n'a pas été
très convaincant jusqu'à présent donc je
regrette qu'il ait pas cette création
par ailleurs il ya des spectacles très
intéressant il y aura évidemment le
celui dont on vient de parler le la
cascade de façon plainte et 9 cm et ses
banlieues au plateau neuf comme c'est un
texte inachevé chaque metteur en scène
écrit un peu sa pièce à partir du
matériau de tchekhov ça c'est toujours
très passionnant il y aura la trilogie
de la villégiature de goldoni qui n'a
pas été remontés en france dans un grand
est depuis très longtemps la dernière
fois qu'on l'avait vu c'était monté par
streller
avec la comédie française c'était cet
éblouissant là c'est jean louis benoit
qui me présente au cloître des carmes
qui est un autre très joli lieu de
d'avignon il y aura un spectacle qui a
déjà beaucoup fait parler de lui parce
qu'il a été créé au théâtre des
célestins lyon minetti de thomas ce
berlin avec michel bouquet tous ceux qui
l'ont vu malheureusement ce n'est pas
mon cas mais disent que c'est un
spectacle absolument exceptionnelle et
puis pour ma part j'ai aussi sélectionné
deux spectacles de claire lannes qui est
un jeune metteur en scène que j'aime
beaucoup qui donnera sous chapiteau en
alternance à la fois l'homme des bois de
tchekhov mais elle connaît très bien de
chekhov elle avait notamment justement
montée plateau 9 de façon extraordinaire
il ya quelques années et puis le don
juan de molière au regard il y en a
beaucoup d'autres enfin bon riche
programme
on en attend beaucoup merci donc on
revient aux pièces elle affiche en ce
moment puisque à cause de can ça fait
trois semaines qu'on on n'a pas eu ce
type de débat on commence avec la
mouette de tchekhov au théâtre des
bouffes du nord mise en scène de
philippe calvario avec irène jacob fort
en son genre jetty jérôme kircher et
johansson magnéto
voilà donc la mouette aux bouffes du
nord philippe cette version punk
hardcore durant laquelle entendu du
madonna
soit une version painco rock 2 à moi et
gore en tous les cas même pas tu es
simplement il ya au cours du spectacle
quatre ou cinq interventions
effectivement dans ce style que vous
venez de dire mais ce qui ne donne pas
une coloration unique univoque au
spectacle non on ne peut pas dire cela
dit ce que conteste moi ça hein je dis
tout de suite on ne voit pas très bien
ce que ça apporte tant il est vrai que
c'est une mise en scène abusive
d'ailleurs c'est une mise en scène très
brillante très plein de talent un type
qui promet dans le manque de brio et
jaffe des chaussures des habits les
jeunes et c'est vrai qu'il m'est
beaucoup de sa personnalité à cette mise
en scène il ya une élégance il ya un
mouvement il ya un risque à quelque
chose de très très fort très exalté très
exaltant mais à mes yeux je suis enfin
superflu plane superflu qu'est ce que
les machins pas quand ce qu'anticipe
quand on a devant soi un texte d'une
telle ou
telle signification mais il est
parfaitement respecté le texte eu peu de
temps de cantonnet vous permettez à
terminer la phrase est terminée là le
développement mais au moins la phrase
quand on a la chance d'avoir se tait on
le on le respecte et surtout aux le
laisse dégager c'est comme un fruit qui
dit dans sa serre on lui est dégagé son
émission pour son émotion pioche cabine
tout de suite jacques or là je vois que
joe moye la mouette ça me fend le coeur
moi je suis pas je suis encore un enfant
à certains égards ou gâteux quand il
m'arrive de moulins n'a rien de pleurer
pendant les scènes d'amour constantin et
nida là j'aime mieux vous dire que
l'amour la tendresse las une superbe
chant lyrique
passe totalement inaperçue notamment au
quatrième as qui est l'acte décisif
où on doit être totalement bouleversée
on est bouleversé à moi à moi parce que
monsieur calvario ne s'est occupé d'une
chose c'est de ses fantasmes
mais c'est jacques this et c'est sur ces
deux caricatures et les personnages qui
font le paysage social de la wii c'est
très intéressant mais les caméras est
passé à côté dans la région de la
réaction alors vous avez le droit de ne
pas aimer à jour mesguich et d'aimer le
lendemain calvario et oui mais excusez
moi c'est exactement le même club à
melzer j'ai beaucoup aimé le spectacle
de mezriche donc jamais parce que la
mise en scène ne vient pas se mettre
comme ça entre le texte et le spectateur
est ce que si tu ne fais pas ça
justement comme dirait que je suis comme
stérile d'abord il ya quatre au service
de sa boîte il est au service d'abord je
vous conjure de ne pas vous fier à ce
que vous venez de voir dans l'extrait on
nous montre à ce moment là une
comédienne qui ne s'est pas joué dans la
pièce elle ne sait pas jouer la comédie
elle joue mal voilà ce qu'on nous montre
donc le spectateur qui ne voit que notre
extrait va penser que tout est joué
comme ça c'est le contraire c'est donc
un extrait très particulier donc ne pas
en tenir compte par pitié deuxièmement
quand je constate qu'un metteur en scène
qui n'a que 25 ans qui en est seulement
à son quatrième spectacle à un art de la
distribution aussi excellent c'est à
dire qu'en face de chaque rôle il a
trouvé le comédien qui convenait qu'il
fallait et que non seulement il l'a bien
distribués mais qu'il les dirige
admirablement qui ne me montre un
spectacle d'une cohérence parfaite et
d'une grande intelligence qui respecte
les situations mises en place par
tchekhov moi je vous dis une mouette
comme ça et on en voit beaucoup c'est
une pièce énormément monté à juste titre
c'est un chef-d'oeuvre mais je n'en
avais pas vu depuis les années 70 quand
l'ancien pilier avait créé au théâtre de
la ville une très belle version c'est
une version d'une force extraordinaire
accord à rien d'aller
à l'essentiel tous les sondeurs même pas
discuter
non mais attendez tous les aspects
fondamentaux de la pièce ils sont
respectés je vois pas en quoi vous
pouvez vous permettre de dire que ça
n'est pas respectée mais ciani non
cadrée et mac j'étais très ému bien sûr
j'ai trouvé gérons qu'il faut absolument
bouleversant
regrette jacques bompard et fanny ardant
jeunes ont vraiment tout bois c'est vrai
qu'elle ressemble physiquement et fanny
ardant mais je ne comparerai
il est à ce jour je ne suis pas le seul
le public visiblement vibre énormément
au spectacle parce que c'est un
spectacle bouleversant vous passez à
côté d'un des évènements de ces derniers
est attentif au public de passer à côté
d'un des événements non mais plus
important était de supérieur c'est fini
c'est vrai aussi c'est à dire que quand
c'est mesguich vous vous aimez passer
mise en scène on la verra disco c'est
triste mais c'est trop tard à vis côté
thierry je vous assure c'est rien par
ses chants à part ces interventions
musicales où effectivement il ya du
madonna il y a de même du tali d'un
moment donné mais ça c'est bon ça
représentait moder attendait ça
représente 5% je vais pas tout le reste
à jouer les vieux réac parce que c'est
utile de mettre du délit d' adam
tchekhov franchement est ce que c'est
est-ce que s est un autre époque
peut-être qu'il ya 30 ans 40 ans c'est
génial cherchons c'est l'hystérie ce
n'est qu'une petite giclée de sites dans
les faits
sur les huit dans le personnage de
chantera d'arcade hymne à la mer georges
et il est drôle elle fait un numéro de
variétés d'étape thomas supporta dans
une pièce dont l'enjeu est là elle est
très drôle je ne dis pas que c'est
mauvais vous êtes la seule différence de
texture est brillant et qu'on s'ennuie
pour nous sans nuit palm ne sort des
petits intermèdes musicaux des postures
et un spa j'aime moi je vous le dis très
franchement c'est la naissance d'un
grand metteur en scène c'est la
naissance de recherche et à g et de 20
succès dont on ne sait pas encore c'est
pas vrai c'est quelqu'un qui va succéder
au jean-pierre vincent shero a faim
c'est la génération qui monte c'est un
événement et présenter les choses comme
vous le faites c'est pousser les gens à
passer à côté d'un événement et d'un
matériel qui a pas pas qu'il faut à pas
les voir je dirais manille je dis encore
une fois que c'est une mise en scène
pleine de qualités mais je dis qu'elles
passent à côté de l'émotion c'est qu'on
vient annoncer qu'elle n'est pas de
qualité si elle passe à côté c'est
bertrand gille avec moi aussi ça veut
rien dire oui c'est ça valait
environ et l'été cenis tenir on parle
giro mais giro que les chanceux cause a
manqué ses sources de cause s'il
c'est-à-dire dégoûté ça me rappelle les
gens qui appelaient à voter pour un
certain candidat avec avec des gants et
en se pinçant le nez non il faut y aller
parce que c'est un chef-d'oeuvre ce
spectacle la tranche a2 on continue avec
les voisins de michel vinaver vert au
théâtre national de la colline mise en
scène d'alain françon avec pierre félix
grave hier hervé pierre julie pilod et
wladimir yordanoff c'est vous qui allez
pitch est cette fois alors vina vers
chez notre ami de gilles c vous savez
qu'il lui est arrivé une mésaventure
terrible c'est il a été recommandé par
le front national comme le seul auteur
vraiment vivant
acceptable alors c'est très curieuse qui
lui est arrivé je crois qu'il est il est
dit dans le monde d'ailleurs on voyait
bien qui comprend pas parce qu'il a
toujours été très clair mon coeur il a
toujours été très clairement engagé à
gauche et le patron c'est absurde je me
suis dit
il faut que tu n'as ni je suis dans le
cadre de vie n'avait il est encore tout
à fait normal que le front national le
récupère vous vous ne comprenez rien à
mon avis
il faut dire que les spectateurs c'est
donc effectivement michel vines inverse
sous le nom de grand père était le
patron de gillette et qu'il écrivait
pièce la nuit et qu'il est le père d'un
ou granby qui jouait d'ailleurs dans les
voisins la création alors les voisins
c'est probablement sa pièce la moins
engagé politiquement et c'est une c'est
une pièce qui s'éteint huis clos si tout
ce passe sur une terrasse mitoyennes et
il ya deux villas qui donne sur cette
terrasse et les voisins là et les
blasons s'entendent merveilleusement ils
s'adorent ils peuvent pas se passer l'un
de l'autre ils passent leur temps à
s'inviter à et un jour les économies de
blasons disparaissent alors seul l'a eu
et son fils savait où les économies
étaient cachées alors là le soupçon
s'insinue il commence une guerre
épouvantable
et puis finalement ils s'aiment
tellement qu'ils vont se réconcilier
alors que l' affaire n'est pas élucidé
alors que c'est probablement le fils de
la e qui cache les lingots d'or mais
l'amitié trop fort ce bien c'est très
drôle dit que c'est pas l'humaniste
c'est un s'étoffe vous connaissez
achille talon et le bassin c'est un peu
ça c'est un univers de bande dessinée
c'est un vaudeville sur réaliste c'est
irrésistible c'est un peu banalisé
malheureusement par la présente
distribution il ya une quinzaine
d'années quand ça a été créé à théâtre
ouvert il y avait de très grands acteurs
comme robert rimbaud et raymond jourdan
anouk grinberg et charles berling la la
distribution est un peu en dessous donc
le spectacle est moins drôle qu'il
n'était mais ça reste très très
passionnant futé sont mortes et je veux
pas entendre aujourd'hui je suis tout à
fait des années que d'ordinaire la
discussion est à peu près courtois ça
n'est pas possible c'est un torrent
d'insultés réciproque je vais mieux
grâce à une verge de neil droite que je
suis quand même le droit de dire qu'il
ya rancune et
j'ai le droit de dire qu'il ya aucune
humanité aucune cher aucune chaleur au
kac heures dans vina verts qui ne
s'intéressent qu'à une chose c'est ton
langage il croit que le langage dicte
les passions moyennant quoi dedans par
dessus bord y avait pas d'humanité
notamment pour les vieux employés des
sociétés qui étaient virés et mis à la
retraite je trouvais qu'il vait pas de
coeur là dedans on parle des voisins au
bar des voisins en général ils avaient
là nous parlons du barça je n'aurais pas
ce que vous venez de dire des voisins
mais ce type qui s'était donné comme une
preuve d'humanité voir humanisme büchi
son amitié plus forte que le larcin non
mais
bien sûr on peut le présenter comme un
chien
on essaie quand même de savoir ce qu'il
ya derrière un texte c'est notre métier
on est en essai de connaître de
comprendre la signification profonde
d'un spectacle je vous dis qu'un
spectacle dos toute la substance se
limite au langage alors bien sûr il ya
des mots s'est passé passé sur pas des
borborygmes il ya des mots qui
définissent des sentiments mais notre
métier nous c'est de savoir quel est le
rapport entre le mot et de sentiments si
le mot est aussi le sentiment est
authentique derrière derrière le mot
c'est bien notre métier il ya plus de
sémiologie danse mais moi je ne fais que
saison nous sommes d'accord je ne sens
rien du tout ça n'a aucun intérêt c'est
sexe on chantait alors évidemment on
écoute l'histoire l'histoire de deux
voies gic de voisinage comme ça c'est un
peu si vous voulez au théâtre ce que le
nouveau roman était heureux j'ai tape ça
mais ça n'est pas attention il n'y a
même pas la même
adresse chez duras c'est un peu les
choses de pérec si vous voulez ça
monsieur là je dis pas que ça serait
super est qu il ya énormément de temps
dans shrek dans les choses enfin la
bouche et le paradis il n'y a qu'une
chose qui intéresse vide à faire c'est
de rapporter l'homme à l'espace ça c'est
son fantasme on rapporte leur l'homme à
l'espace et surtout on réduit au maximum
l'espace ou détruit même l'espace et par
là même on détruit là bas ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout dire ça me fait
ça m'emmerde de voir pendant une heure
et demie dialectique entre quatre
personnages sur une terrasse sur une
terrasse c'est un mélange de labiche je
me vois pas dû le poivre cette pièce les
voisins c'est un mélange de labiche et
de 2,2 se réalise il mesurerait mais je
suivais s'amusait beaucoup plus que ça
il faut l'aborder avec beaucoup plus de
simplicité d'humour et de légèreté pour
une fois ce sont d'habitude vos qualités
là il me semble relever ses dunes mais
jamais d'une raideur insoutenable
vraiment c'est une attitude le mécanisme
biasi l'avait reçue de mes cannes
comment vous aviez assisté à la création
oui en 86 85 ainsi si j'avais vécu
berling d'ailleurs vous allez vous aviez
déjà cette sensation mais totalement
jeux gc la transaction de vente ou
levina vers dis pas que vit la ville et
vivait jeudi cinq minarets viole et
inintéressant jeudi que cette
transcription de l'awb de ce réalisme
qui est un fou réaliste parce que c'est
complètement artificiers réaliser le
sait le réalisme par les mots non car
les situations sont très rationnel c'est
pas du surréalisme c'est du lac du
réalisme artificiel moi ça ne parle pas
à ma sensibilité je n'empêche pas chaque
perso d'aimer ça et je ne vois pas
pourquoi on se dispute on est chacun
dans la vie en essayant d'expliquer le
mieux possible pour que les lecteurs en
tire une conclusion et ayew n'aille pas
selon la confiance qui fait soit moi
soit à jacques moi si on me fait
confiance on ne va pas voir villa vert
mais je comprends parfaitement qu'on
fasse confiance à mon adamou partenaires
école à vila maire se tait à
déshumaniser sec desséché un
entomologiste de ne m'intéresse pas
c'est tout je préfère shakespeare mais a
vu par
malheureusement nous n'aurons pas le
temps de parler du change d'une nuit
d'été c'est bien malheureux quant à la
salle malraux si c'est que nous allons
vous séparez puisque ces derniers débats
théâtre de l'année et de la saison de
dix ans et que vous allez vous séparer
sur une dispute hexion un petit peu
triste de partir en vacances non mais
dans la coulisse d honorer
la
dernière fois
parce que franchement ça m'ennuie et de
terminer la saison comme ça merci à tous
les deux après les pubs place au pari de
garder arpentés par jérôme cassou et
place ensuite à notre visite guidée du
ciné des cinéastes de la ville de clichy
a plus
chers amis chers ennemis 3 foireux on se
retrouve pour le pari des galeries
arpentés par jérôme cassou magnéto
il
ce tour des galeries parisiennes
commence dare dare à la galerie vu par
le photographe coréen il dit et song
pack de nombreux artistes coréens
profite de la coupe du monde pour
illuminer médiatiquement leur production
il y ait son bac et donc coréen
d'origine il a grandi aux états unis
puis décide de vivre en europe ce
voyageur dans l'âme inonde sa
photographie d'une présence secrète joue
avec la lumière pour créer des
apparitions sur expose parfois assez
saine et cherche des noirs profonds et
veloutée il superpose les plans les
floute afin de créer du mystère
certains verront dans ses personnages
des revenants des fantômes ou tout
simplement des présences humaines
éthérée et d'une évanescence troublante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre galerie autre style fabrice
langlade crée des objets charnelle grâce
à des matières rappelant la peau ou même
des organes en latex qui semble plus
humide il parle de l'homme avec beaucoup
d'humour il transforme un mur en surface
cutanée avec pustuleux petit bouton qui
vu de côté évoque des champignons
miniature c'est avec une vision presque
enfantine qu'il évoque le passé à
travers ces toupies vergne
[Applaudissements]
à côté d'elle des tableaux qu'il faut
voir comme des cadrages en gros plan son
décor dans lequel l'artiste aurait
laissé les empreintes de ses doigts
[Musique]
mais la vraie découverte vient de ces
figurines en matériaux de synthèse kama
sutra épinglé et d'une délicatesse
sulfureuse
[Musique]
tous
enfin la galerie la rave ainsi exposé
l'artiste guy ritchie qui il est cheikh
et s'inscrit dans le cadre de la saison
tchèque en france entre mai et décembre
2002 il a transformé la galerie en une
chambre censés appartenir à medusa jeune
femme moderne matraqués par un monde
sans pitié où luxe et cocaïne son talent
au quotidien
[Musique]
il expose sa coiffeuse quand on se
penche dessus on peut voir que l'artiste
a transformé ses flacons de parfum en
seringue une manière symbolique de
critiquer la consommation vu comme une
drogue
il expose sous verre une seringue en
cristal vision satirique ou mort et
plaisir sont placées au rang d'oeuvres
d'art
lyrique chagny qui est un artiste à
découvrir
il est devenu en quelques mois la
coqueluche du marché de l'art
contemporain
[Musique]
merci jérôme cassou est maintenant sous
le regard expert de coline serreau on
enchaîne avec la visite guidée du ciné
des cinéastes 6 au 7 de l'avenue de
clichy une salle fétiche fondée par des
cinéastes pour des cinéphiles clémence
badault et à les changer de bobines
magnéto
parce qu'il leur fallait un lieu une
centaine de réalisateurs regroupés au
sein de l'association l'arpp à qui il ya
50 le cinéma des cinéastes la salle de
l'avenue de clichy qui existe depuis
1932 est devenu leur maison
parce que c'est ça que vous ici salah la
structure faire
ça c'est vraiment bourg
j'adore
l'ancien cabaret n'est pas qu'une simple
salle de projection les réalisateurs
s'approprient l'espace
on se sent chez soi ici d'autant plus
que le lieu très beau il a été serré
beaucoup de goût il a été à la fois très
confortable très moderne et en même
temps très assez dingue avec tous côtés
on a laissé les ruines on a c'est le
contraire du pop corn quoi
je vais demander à ce qu'on me prête là
il ya un espèce de plateau assez grand
au dessus du bar j'ai répété chaos là
avec rachida brakni être une cro et
vincent lindon
pendant quatre cinq semaines c'était
sympa parce que c'était avait
l'impression que c'est qu'elle s'était
aussi fait pour ça c'est un lieu pour
les cinéastes quoi la maison des
cinéastes accueille le public et propose
une programmation variée seule exigence
des réalisateurs qu'on voit ici des
films qui ne sont projetés nulle part
ailleurs comme la moitié gauche du frigo
de philippe falardeau présenté lors de
la semaine du cinéma québécois
c'est un très bon film c'est un film
très drôle très
très chouette voilà un film que j'ai
beaucoup aimé voir qui est que je ne
quittais même pas sortie qui n'est pas
vendu et qui qu'on a qu'on a pu voir ici
quoi c'est ça qui est important c'est de
pouvoir faire des choses aussi qu'au bon
sinon on va au gaumont du coin où elle
faisait du coin mais là ici c'est autre
chose il va devenir très fort ce
cinéma-là des des gens jeunes qui font
des films dans des béquilles qui ont un
autre langage une autre qui n'obéissent
pas à des as des as des formules quoi
[Musique]
quand on a un lieu on est on existe
autrement que si on se réunit dans un
bureau je dirais quand on fait des
choses quand on réunit des gens autour
de nous et quand on montre ce qu'on fait
c'est notre fonction c'est de réunir des
gens dans une salle et des rendre
heureux cette salle permet au
réalisateur de se réunir et de défendre
ensemble leur conception du septième art
merci clémence badault et maintenant
mesdames et messieurs voici patrice
parmentier
aujourd'hui moi je vais vous parler
d'une couleur qui le bleu et pourquoi
aujourd'hui on est tous semblaient en
fait c'est tant mieux pendant mais c'est
pour cacher la marque n'a pas droit de
sava télévision ont annoncé ces
quartiers que ces plumes évidemment donc
le coût de l'ébriété la couleur préférée
des américains des français pour une
large majorité après celles vers donc on
s'est quand même envoyé frédéric en
illustration notre ami patrice aussi
donc en fait le bleu ou et thiery le but
est une couleur qu'elle est sa très
discrète voire inexistantes depuis entre
l'antiquité xiième siècle en fait ça
n'existait pas quasiment le bleu
pour preuve c'est que les couleurs
primaires était le rouge le blanc le
noir et à l'époque le ciel d'ailleurs
été rouge brésil justement ya les
philologues de qui ont étudié les écrits
des des grecs et des latins se sont dit
que les grecs et des romains étaient
aveugles aux bleus ne voyez pas le bleu
ils ont parié cette théorie au 19e
siècle il pensait que des est donc en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que il
détestait le bleu parce que symbolisait
les barbares les germains et c est donc
une une personne qui avait les yeux
bleus c'était un signe de disgrâce
physique hop dehors une forte et une
femme aux yeux bleus et une femme peu
vertueuses cds grecs et des romains
non moi non ouais ouais choisi par
montant - donc jusqu'au 2ème siècle en
fait les seuls à avoir vraiment porter
du bleu ste les paysans et qu'est ce
qu'ils savaient pas ce qu'était un petit
peu et qu'est ce qui s'est passé au
xiiie siècle pour que d'un seul coup le
bleu devienne une couleur à la mode
aristocratique etc etc eh bien c'est la
vierge la vierge a lancé le bleu voilà
parce qu'en fait avant elle était
représentée de pas mal de couleur foncée
parce qu'elle portait le deuil de
de son fils évidemment mort sur la croix
et donc qu'à ce moment là rennes les
pintes au xiiie siècle ont décidé de la
peindre en bleu qui est une couleur
assez lumineuse mais qui quand même
portait le deuil du fils et donc c'est
devenu un effet de mode autour de la
vierge si bien que j'ai oublié de vous
montrer tous mes panneaux dans cette
voie là donc ça ce sont là voyez les
premières illustrations de la vierge au
xiiie siècle
donc été effectivement c'était une école
une icône voilà c'était une top model à
partir de là le premier roi à s'inspirer
de cette couleur fut saint-louis donc
louis 9 au xiiie siècle était le premier
roi à porter du bleu et donc au xiiie
siècle les plus grands le but est
devenue la couleur de la royauté donc le
roi d'italie le roi d'angleterre le roi
d'allemagne le roi de france porter le
bleu donc c'est un seul siècle bleu est
devenu la couleur à n'oublie à ne pas
partout les leur maison voilà ça c'était
un peu plus tard et donc après est
arrivé heureusement que celui-là mais
après l'arrivée thierry ardisson au
xvème siècle parce que c'est le siècle
du noir peut
donc effectivement c'est la couleur
moral il fallait chasser toutes ces
dépenses ostentatoires sur ses tenues
colorées le noir est arrivé me signe de
modestie de vertus ailleurs détourné
à l'époque c'est prochaine avec nous
et sinon ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
il y avait du coup des couleurs étaient
interdites pour certains métiers qui
avait quitté signe de respect de dignité
pouvait pas porter autre chose que le
noir donc c'était pas animateur de
télévision c'était magistrat cet éclair
et puis à des situations qui ordonnait
le noir évidemment d'être veufs ou
veuves on pouvait pas avoir de couleur
donc voyez c'était et puis après il ya
eu des rois ou du moins là vous allez à
droite le duc de bourgogne qui était en
noir mais aussi pour marquer ça et puis
vous avez évidemment lutter les grandes
figures c'était quand même la couleur du
protestantisme d'époque donc à ce
moment-là au xvème siècle donc toutes
les couleurs sont interdites sauf le but
est qu'ils arrivent à cohabiter ce que
doubler la seule couleur à peu près
autorisé dans cette
dévotion au noir et donc c'est ainsi que
le bleu qu'on continue sa traversée et
là on arrive au xviiie siècle hélas le
fils spirituel de tesson quelque chose
les remonte au site notamment dans la
durée et dans l'italie là on arrive
effectivement le bleu devient xviiie
siècle à la couleur préférée
ddd occidentaux donc en use et
l'aquarelle de goethe donc là on est
dans l'ère du romantisme avec cette
dévotion pour le bleu c'est là qu'on a
les comptes bleus l'oiseau bleu qu'est
l'être idéal et c'est donc frédéric pour
nous sommes pris par le par le temps les
bleus à la vous avez en bas à gauche
effectivement le la révolution parce
qu'effectivement le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge est arrivé à ce moment là et
pourquoi on a gardé plus tôt bloqué deux
autres balles et deux autres ont incarné
des idéologies plutôt radicale le blanc
pour la royauté le rouge ensuite pour
les mouvements révolutionnaires un peu
socialiste effectivement le but est
restée la couleur consensuelle des trois
couleurs du drapeau français et puis
pour terminer le les premiers soldats
des premiers soldats en bleu date de
1792 il était là pour défendre la
république c'est peut-être pourquoi ces
messieurs chirac
pageau spam et chevènement ou même le
pen avait utilisent les bleus dans leur
campagne électorale dans l'air dans
leurs affiches et
donc c'était les 3 donc voici donc toute
cette histoire est formidablement
raconté dans ce livre de michel
pastoureau donc l'histoire d'une couleur
le bleu et ça c'était très intéressant
donc et puis pour terminer donc le xxème
siècle en france tous les grands corps
d'état passent au glauque que ce soit
des pompiers les gendarmes les policiers
les marins des facteurs les douaniers et
les sportifs c'est pour ça qu'on va
pouvoir chanter allez les bleus dès
vendredi avec philippe
et patrice
est fini pour aujourd'hui
et demain 10 45 projeter des cultures
spéciales peu la peine q
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus